[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome
I am the John closer at the Provost of
the University and it's my distinct
pleasure to be able to introduce to you
today the President of the Republic of
Costa Rica Luis Guillermo Solis Rivera
let me begin by thanking the Institute
of latin-american studies for
co-sponsoring this event and
acknowledged the presence here of the
Minister of Foreign Affairs and worship
Manuel Gonzalez and the first radiant
Costa Rica Mercedes Pena's Noemi I would
also like to thank you all and all the
members of delegation from Costa Rica
that are here for joining us as well as
chaplain Davis and Professor Joseph
Stiglitz who are also participating
president Solis was born in San Jose
Costa Rica in 1958 the son of a
shoemaker he has spent his life immersed
in the words in the worlds of academia
and government he received degrees in
history and Latin American Studies from
the University of Costa Rica and Tulane
he was a Fulbright Scholar and has
taught at the University of Costa Rica
the University of Michigan and Florida
International University his political
career has included high-level positions
in Costa Rica's Ministry of Foreign
Affairs including ambassador-at-large
for Central American affairs and
Director General for policy under his
leadership Costa Rica has been lauded
for its embrace of sustainable
development and the quality of life its
citizens enjoy the country sits
regularly atop the Happy Planet Index
recognized for its high life expectancy
low ecological footprint and the
overwhelm the overall well-being of its
people it's a great honor to welcome the
president back to Columbia this year he
seems always to be engaged in the most
intractable and critical decisions and
concerns of the day last year he came to
Morningside Heights to discuss the
migration crisis that continues to grip
Latin America and the world
you may remember that his country was
and remains at the center of that crisis
with migrants fleeing violence in El
Salvador Guatemala and Honduras now as
well Venezuela to seek refuge in
countries like Costa Rica and the United
States today President Solis has come to
discuss yet another daunting crisis that
threatens to upend a global peace and
stability and that is nuclear war this
past year Costa Rica led a conference at
the United Nations that drafted an
international treaty banning nuclear
weapons in July more than 120 nations
voted to adopt the agreement the first
of its kind and yesterday at the UN
nations began signing that document as
expected the nine countries that possess
nuclear weapons including the United
States did not participate most members
of NATO also abstained some critics
contend that the agreement will do
little to deter countries like North
Korea Russia and China from keeping
their nuclear arms supporters argue that
their actions will hopefully lead
building momentum to the growing
pressure that will entail nations to
begin thinking seriously about the
pledge that president former President
Obama made that is the goal of
eliminating nuclear weapons altogether
I'm sure you're eager to hear about this
issue from president's release today his
address is entitled towards a nuclear
weapons free world the nuclear ban
treaty so please join me in giving a
warm welcome to the president of the
Republic of Costa Rica at least
Guillermo Solis Rivera
welcome all
thank you very much and good morning to
all I do thank on behalf of my
delegation myself and says the great
opportunity to be here and I thank dr.
Coates worth Latin American Studies
Institute and all of you for allowing me
to come and share with you some thoughts
on this very important issue of
denuclearization and and why it is that
Costa Rica continues to support this
pathway towards a more secure world free
of nuclear weapons and built upon the
notions of international solidarity
peace and justice now in preparing for
this lecture I prepared a big speech but
then I realized that maybe it would be
more interesting to propose a different
approach today so what I'm gonna do is
I'll give you a ten-minute opening
remark presentation and then I'm going
to ask ambassador Elaine white who
presided over the Commission that
drafted the convention to ignore the
human the nuclear weapons to come and
speak for another 10 minutes and then
open up for discussions I think that
this would probably be more interesting
and then you get two speakers for the
price of one and you get the lead figure
in the negotiation who was who is our
ambassador to the UN organizations in
Geneva to have the opportunity to share
with you the highlights of the
negotiations you know as a professor as
an academic and I've been a professor
for 35 years I always treasured the
opportunity to learn from the
from the makers of these international
agreements their experiences and where
were the knots of the negotiation and
the more difficult parts and how the
inner dealings of the negative
negotiations went about and since we
don't have the limitations of secrecy at
least I don't maybe she has to be more
less candid than I but I'm sure she
won't be she's also a professor III
thought that it would be interesting
simply to hear some of her insights to
the process and how she sees from the
insights of the system of the United
Nations system the likelihood of the
treaty to continue and raveling in the
next few years just yesterday
just yesterday 50 out of the original
122 crea creators of the trainee signed
signed it so we now see that process
underway once we have 50 ratifications
and there were two or three that were
issued yesterday as at the time of the
signing and I designed ceremony then the
treaty will enter into effect so you
know we are very hopeful that this will
happen in the next few years
at any rate let me begin by saying that
the aspiration of a nuclear-free work
world is something that makes sense and
I say this because quite frankly
sometimes we'll get too philosophical
about it and I think there is a case to
be made about the morality of nuclear
weapons and how we should look at it you
know and sometimes I have proposed
following the logic that are another
Costa Rican president once used that for
all practical purposes the way in which
we deal with drugs in and the way drugs
are seeing
in many developed countries are for
moral purposes equally to equal to what
one can say about weapons regular
weapons and clearly weapons of my
destruction in what's what's the
ultimate moral difference between
selling a product that kills white and
non-white youngsters in the developed
world to that logic of weapons that kill
not unknot white and white young people
in the third world it's the same thing
it's no difference at all from a moral
point of view but you know beyond that
beyond the ethics of war which can be so
complicated and and so absurd there is
the question of do we want to survive or
not and obviously this time around and
the 72nd General Assembly of the United
Nations who have been talking about that
all the time we we did that when we
talked about climate change
whose commitments in in the Paris
Accords and marrakech costa rica
continents continues to uphold at all
costs
we feel that there should be no
regression whatsoever on those
agreements and that the world should
stand very firmly to to ensure that the
very difficult difficulty crafted
mechanism in paris is kept and it moves
forward may it be the case of nuclear
weapons maybe in the case of inclusion
and particularly that of women which we
also have been fostering strongly
for the last few years in the United
Nations as part of a high-level panel
that was convened by the
secretary-general of the United Nations
Costa Rica has has insisted in the need
of of women to be part of to be included
creatively forcefully and decently into
the world's economy and that they should
be economically empowered which is the
next generation of agreements that are
much needed other than the political
ones I mean giving the women the
opportunity to become active members of
the economy in equal conditions as men
we have been upholding that well now we
have been think talking about issues
upon which the future of humanity
depends and yes there is a debate
clearly regarding the the convenience of
having or not having weapons of mass
destructions such as nuclear weapons
curtailed by international and
agreements in fact there is a car a
discussion about multilateralism whether
the logic of international solidarity
should be in Poland post upon or or
fostered in order to limit the
individual capacity of states to do
whatever they want
that was clearly poised in the United
Nations this week but we feel very
strongly that it also comes to be a
matter of common sense do we want to
survive or we don't I mean are we
willing to make small national
sacrifices in order to ensure that the
larger global challenges are adequately
dealt with and who is there to do the
job so you know in in with with nuclear
matters this is this is the case clearly
the case in Costa Rica which as you know
is a country that has no army in 1948 we
abolished the Armed Forces as a
permanent institution we confide on
international law and the police force
and it has sufficed so far
to to grant the security we need in the
country and allow us to invest the
monies that would have gone to the Armed
Forces into other purposes education and
housing and health and so forth the the
fact that we can count on the vast
majority of the general UN General
Assembly Member States in this quest for
a denuclearized world is something that
upon which our own survival depends and
this is the case for most countries in
the world you know and yes we do
understand believe me the complexities
which D nuclei rise in the world entails
I mean there's no question about it and
this is not only a matter of politics
it's also a matter we were just
discussing this with ambassador white
comments when we were coming driving
towards Colombia you know the the
technicalities of denuclearization are
to be dealt with and it has to be a very
carefully drafted process we cannot
Stampede over the the technical
questions that denuclearizing imposes
upon Nations and everybody has to agree
in good faith and things that are not
common in international politics or in
politics in general ought to be put in
front of these agreements so you know
I'm not a man well can't I'm not a
pacifist
by all means and I think that sometimes
you have to resort to force in order to
protect the larger good but this is not
the case with nuclear war look at Wars
based upon the notion of extermination
there's there's no way around it I mean
you you cannot once once you use those
weapons the path towards mutual assured
destruction is open it's wide open and
it would be very difficult to imagine
that a new nuclear attack because we've
only had two so far over Hiroshima and
Nagasaki
would be limited in scope and truly one
can say that the likelihood of a
government making the voluntary move of
destroying another one using nuclear
weapons is unlikely at this point more
or less unlikely okay but there are
other possibilities as well not only the
fact that a rogue state could start a
war which would immediately unravel
reactions that could end up in a in a
larger conflict with the potential of
extermination of the of the human family
but also terrorism which as we know
could take hold of some of these weapons
and and cost tremendous damage with or
without the support of a state so far
this is only the has been in the minds
of James Bond films but but it could
happen we've seen unexpected things
occurring in in the world during the
last few years and I fear that we could
see even worse ones in the near future
so I think we ought to understand and
this is part of a new reality and the
fact that the superpowers the members of
b5 the members of the Security Council
the UN Security Council which of course
are nuclear weapon bearers and other
states that are not members of the
Security Council but do have weapons and
that we know of and there may be other
countries that have the weapons and we
don't you don't know that they do or
officially do not know that they have
the weapons are not participating in the
treaty and a lot of people say well if
they're not in then the treaty is
useless because the ones who should be
involved in the first line are not
willing to put on their part I quite
frankly and respectfully
submit that they're wrong 122 countries
says voices as they have been put in
that declaration sends a very strong
moral message and also our testimonies
of the new condition in the world in the
world community for once it says a lot
about the end of the Cold War and the
possibility of nations to take decisions
by themselves aside from the original
the original bearers of a world of world
control secondly it also bears testimony
to the strength of civil society which
took a very important part in the
construction of these arraignment I like
to quote Tip O'Neill you know the the
famous chair of the House of
Representatives for so many years in the
United States when he saw him when he
said that oh look all politics is local
well this is a good example of that in
the weight of civil society within
countries and the international civil
society as a whole in supporting this
effort is something to be reckoned with
and I think it shows the importance of
of the people taking control of certain
issues that used to be presented to us
to the people as Givens not anymore
there is a voice a very strong voice
coming from the civil society and it
also bears
I think testimony to the fact that there
were more conscientious of the global
responsibilities which we have we have
grown to be more aware of a fact that no
small international actions have huge
national consequences and that unless we
are capable of fatha me
the depth of those consequences to our
well-being and to the well-being of
future generations this is the whole
idea of sustainability Geoff's are steps
act is not here now because he had to
another engagement but we have been so
we should be so grateful to his efforts
to to make us understand the important
sustainability I mean the long-term as a
transcendental feature of today's world
I mean that logic of sustainability the
fact that very small impacts can happen
in the international system can have
huge consequences in the local arena is
something that I think we should
treasure very much and this is an
awareness that has brought the
international community to higher levels
of maturity higher levels of
understanding you know we we live in a
world of high speed decisions position
making and one of the things I I
would like to go to when I finished my
period as president is the possibility
to think before I have to decide you
know sometimes you know this thing has
forced us to make decisions without
thinking what we do because simply we
have to respond so fast that there's no
time for reflection whatsoever and an
immediate being the immediate response
to everything has brought out as part of
our pragmatic way of seeing life you
know we make decisions as a matter of
fact all the time which is fine I mean
generally I don't think that this is
necessarily negative but there are parts
in in the in the all or the larger
perspective of life where you need to to
think to sit down and think and think in
the long term and be able to see the
wider perspective the longer the longer
frontier of things and and to transcend
the medians in mediate well with nuclear
weapons and with the facility of
destroying the world with climate change
in the facility of hurting the world we
have that possibility your grandparents
my grandparents were here my
great-grandparents didn't have the
possibility to make a difference in many
of the things they endured we do we have
the technical nor the capacities we have
the scientific knowledge we have the
sociological perspective to do things
differently and this is why I find this
treaty to ban nuclear weapons to be so
immensely important important because we
can make a difference yes it's true that
you know any country bearing nuclear
weapons can just push the button and do
a horrible mess around the world and
that that can be done with or without a
treaty I mean if you look at that
pragmatically that's that and so let us
all pray to our different in a different
religious
understandings that this main item it
may not happen but if we're able to
build up a human understanding edifice
of conventions of laws and norms and of
political logics that could prevent that
we should be able we should and we must
do it for the sake of the rest of
humanity that is not been born yet and
all of us are in one way or another
responsible for their well-being as
somebody else was responsible for ours
back in the past so I'm I'm extremely
grateful with the 122 countries that
agreed upon the treaty I'm very grateful
Dan and also very honored that a Costa
Rican woman chaired the committee that
was able to put together this convention
and that she was also a and she's also
been a professor so she's an academic
she's a member of this community
so we're useful after all dr. Cosworth
even when some people think the
universities would happen could be
closed with no consequences and now I
would like to to give her the
opportunity to tell us a little bit
about the about the the procedure how
this this this treaty this convention
was was was crafted and what are some of
the details that would be interesting
for such an audience to understand the
immensity of the task that we have in
front of us and I can tell you that as a
small country Costa Rica has very small
has very little possibility to be a
world actor in in terms of you know the
larger picture we are small and but we
do have the moral authority to call for
for international peace because this is
how we have been able to survive in a
very difficult world in 72 years after
these explosions in Japan and bearing in
mind that there are still people who are
suffering from those impacts that he
Baku says whom we have been who have
been very present along the the
negotiation of this treaty that we can
still do a lot to prevent and to make it
unnecessary to restore to nuclear war as
a symbol of the new times we live so let
us be optimistic and hopeful that in
shaping this new world who could do it
on the basis of justice and the voices
of peace and sustainable development to
all and I now would like to introduce
you to ambassador Elaine white and then
after that open for questions from the
moderator will help us with that but I
would like everybody to feel welcome to
ask questions both to ambassador got
white to myself and to participate in
what I hope will be a very interesting
debate with the rest of the time we have
available for this conference I thank
you very much ambassador
[Applause]
good morning to you all I would like to
say that I am very honored to be able to
share this podium with presidential ism
we all know that it has been a very
renown scholar in Costa Rica for many
many years so I'm very happy to be able
to to share this experience in them so
much here also the knowledge that we
have gained in this process one of the
the first question that I have been
asked is why Costa Rica many people have
asked you know the nuclear disarmament
is high politics and you don't even have
an army how can you contribute to this
process if you don't you know even have
a knowledge about military affairs so
the first issue I would I would mention
the first response to that is that of
course we do understand the nature of
international politics and the
international politics of the sentiment
which is essential for conducting this
process but at the same time in Costa
Rica is an expert in decision-making
within the rule of law we are a
consolidated democracy in all Costa
Rican citizens it is in our DNA to be
able to to know how to conduct
decision-making with this a democratic
inclusive process that is at the same
time respectful of the rule of law in an
international diplomatic conference
there has been called for by the General
Assembly it's a very formal
decision-making process so the first
contribution that we
that we gave this processes this very I
would say entrenched know-how that we
are Costa Ricans have to conduct
processes in a transparent and inclusive
matter that at the same time is very
respectful of the rules secondly it is
true that Costa Rica has been engaged in
norm development throughout the years
especially Costa Rica when a president
Solis was a director-general of foreign
policy promoted in the comprehensive
Convention on nuclear disarmament back
in the year 1996 but this is not I mean
we were not discussing a comprehensive
convention the General Assembly in
December of 2016
took the decision to convene and
negotiate in conference to prohibit
nuclear weapons and the first thing that
the conference that the General Assembly
did was to provide a very
straightforward mandate for this
conference which was to negotiate a
prohibition instrument a treaty that
would first of all strengthen and
complement the current architecture for
nuclear disarmament and
non-proliferation and this is very
important because we were not we were
not creating a norm from scratch we were
creating a norm already from the
knowledge that we had in the system of
what worse what does not work especially
also departing from the already a great
language in in in other texts and
treaties which was a very important
factor of why we were able to finish
with the negotiation in three weeks
which is a record time
in diplomatic history at the same time
this process had to be inclusive it had
to response to the sense of urgency that
the new international situation demands
we had to conclude as soon as possible
and we had to make a clear distinction
between the process of prohibiting the
nuclear weapons and the future steps
that are needed later on for us the
total elimination of nuclear weapons
which means at the actual negotiation of
disarmament missions measures among the
stake I mean the the nuclear powers and
let me say then the the then if
mentioned very briefly some highlights
about the content of the treaty and I
will refer to the process first of all I
would mention three aspects of the
treaty that I think it is very important
that we all know citizens of the world
first of all that nuclear weapons were
the only weapons of mass destruction
that had not been prohibited in
international law so the first thing
that this treaty does article one is to
undertake that prohibition and it has a
very category prohibition for a wide
range of activities related to nuclear
weapons from development testing in
general terms production manufacturer
manufacturer acquisition possession
stockpiling transfer use or threatening
to use the nuclear weapons which is this
was a very controversial aspect because
by prohibiting the threat of use one is
also the legitimizing nuclear deterrence
it is also prohibited to assist or
encourage coherent acts and to allow
other states
install or deploy nuclear weapons on
their territory so it is a very
straightforward very comprehensive
prohibition norm in addition of course
it will be very easy to negotiate a
treaty among nuclear non-nuclear States
and that was the initial focus of the
treaty but the conference was completely
determined to open the door for nuclear
States to join the treaty from day one
so that created a very important
complexity in the negotiation so that we
create norms and procedures not only for
the accession of non-nuclear States but
also for the accession of nuclear powers
meaning a state that has possessed
nuclear weapons can destroy the nuclear
weapons and enjoy the treaty having
already become a non-nuclear weapon
States but at the in addition there
there are provisions for States
interstates to adhere to the treaty by
committing to the alert the nuclear
weapons and to submit a proposal for the
destruction of their nuclear programs
that has to be approved by the
conference of state parties so of course
they can they are invited to join but
they have to comply with certain
requisites in addition we were able to
establish an appropriate institutional
setting to further develop the regime
and to further develop all the issues
that we were not able to negotiate the
aid at this moment because the
complexity of negotiating nuclear
disarmament and its verification
is well went beyond the time that we
have to negotiate so we gave the
conference of state parties the
responsibility to further develop the
measures evenly they're legally binding
in the in the shape of additional
protocols to the treaty to further
develop the measures for nuclear
disarmament
in addition which is also interesting
consistent with other international
humanitarian human rights law in
accordance with the principle of state
sovereignty the treaty places primary
responsibility and control for aiding
victims in remediate remediating
contaminated environments all the states
affected by the use or test of nuclear
weapons and this is of course
groundbreaking however since the treaty
frames nuclear weapons as a threat to
the whole humanity it establishes their
address in the harms of nuclear violence
is the duty of all peoples therefore
article 7 expands the circle of
responsibility to all members of the
treaty which are required to cooperate
and provide technical material and
financial assistance to help other state
parties to meet their obligation systems
of victim assistance and environmental
remediation in addition ericone 7.6
asserts that states joining the treaty
that have used or tetanus tested nuclear
weapons have a responsibility to provide
adequate assistance to affected State
Parties again this is groundbreaking I
would like to mention some aspects of
the process because this this treaty has
many indicators of success in
international and diplomatic history
first of all this is
as far as we are concerned the treaty
that Nick was negotiated in the shortest
period so we were with the the process
now goes benefited from different
determinants that I would like to
mention first of all we had a very clear
mandate and the mandate as I said was to
confine the instrument to the
prohibition norm and not to start
developing the processes of nuclear
disarmament which are completely complex
and that should be devoted once the
nuclear and states are negotiated at the
time second the conference benefited
from the fact that the rules of
procedure of the conference were
approved from day one which left the
delegations with other options but to
devote to the discussions of the
substance substantive matters third the
conference benefited from methodological
innovation and this is where I would
like to bring the issue of the role of
academia in the processing way why was a
conference innovative the conference was
innovated because for the first time in
the settlement affairs we were able to
open for real interactive dialogue
between scholars scientists civil
society representatives victims both Eva
coaches victims of of the use in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki but also of
victims of nuclear testing throughout
the world and delegation scientists and
engineers so first influence of academia
being our academic was that we promoted
confrontation of ideas that was very
helpful and refreshing for all the
delegations and it helped in
prove the knowledge creation management
exchanged among delegations in or did
the conference that was an open and
inclusive process at some point I did
constitute it as some sort of a very
informal body of scholars that were
advisors to the presidency to which I
resorted to so that they could give me
very fresh ideas and analysis of the
process and many times I asked scholars
and experts and scientists to read what
we were negotiating and confront the and
I confronted their input with
delegations that were negotiating these
aspects and sometimes the guys didn't
like that very much but at the end it
was very helpful at some point some of
some of some even came to me and said
you know we are government delegates I
mean we are not here to negotiate with
you know scholars but it was truly
helpful to be able to shake and to into
everyday stress test the most technical
aspects of the treaty they were being
negotiated by the by the delegations and
I think overall the conference was able
to avert many risks that the opponents
of the treaty had mentioned that the
treaty was going to have precisely
because of that open exchange between
academia experts in delegations and last
but not least the conference was able to
benefit from a very very strong
political determination they had been
forged throughout the years
and that grew out of the frustration of
these 122 of the majority of the
international community with a slow pace
of multilateral nuclear disarmament
negotiations and also this determination
also benefited from the increasing
evidence and updated evidence of the
scientific that the scientific and the
diplomatic and the academic community
were able to exchange about the
catastrophic consequences of nuclear
weapons and what exactly it would mean
today in 2017 or 2016 what do you mean
today to have a nuclear detonation and
the scientific evidence was so so
horrendous for the international
community that international community
decided that the way in which we discuss
nuclear disarmament in multilateral fora
could not be only focused on nuclear
deterrence or you know just the
determinants of of nuclear neutral of
you assured destruction but it had to
incorporate the discussion about the
catastrophic humanitarian consequences
and this movement grew politically and
socially in such terms that all the
delegations that were there the 122
countries were a very solid support
coalition Bill's able and determined to
bring the treaty to a conclusion very
soon in addition of course I would also
I also like to think that the presidency
also was a good contributing factor and
of course I would have to to come to the
de roda Costa Rica has played in
International Politics in the fact that
we were perceived as an honest broker
the negotiation meaning that we were not
neutral but we were completely committed
to the achievement of the of the of the
mandate that we received from the
General Assembly we were committed in in
making the conference move towards the
fulfillment of the mandate but we were
perceived as an honest broker among
other things not only because of the of
the roller coaster it has played but
also because I myself had not been
engaged in nuclear politics before so it
was a fresh new leadership and people
could not encapsulate me in in one
thought or the other and that gave me a
lot of possibility to bridge to bridge
our positions last but not least there
is a point in which of course the
presidency has to has to promote at some
point has to offer the conference with a
proposed text the conference has to
negotiate the text and the president has
to update that text that is under
discussion but there is a point in which
the presidency understands that there is
no more room not only in terms of time
but also in terms of negotiating in
terms of negotiation maneuvering there
is no more space to further discuss and
the broad of the presidency is to make
the conference understand that what we
have before us is the best deal that we
can arrive at him to convince them that
this is the deal and you can go for it
and of course it's very difficult but at
some point it was very successful in
that terms in those terms and we were
able to to have a solid
group of the majority the vast majority
of the international community to agree
on this new international norm that from
now on we have to devote ourselves to
strengthening and and developing the
links appropriate links with the rest of
the architectural meaning the Treaty of
the non-proliferation of nuclear weapons
as well as the treaty on the complaint
of the that prohibits the nuclear
testing and the rest of the architecture
both institutional and conventional
regimes that exist in in the UK at the
UN level but above all we do hope that
this treaty is going to push is going to
give a very important political push for
the ceramic negotiations together with
the urgency and the urge that we acquire
by just by reading the news about what
is going on in the world I want to thank
you and you'll be ready for an exchange
professor if you want to ask me
questions
[Applause]
Thank You president Solis and ambassador
white my name is Steven Andrade the
program manager at the Institute or
Latin American Studies and I have the
honor to moderate this Q&A session as
you will see there are two microphones
on the aisle we ask you to please line
up behind the microphones and state your
questions please remember to first give
your name and the school affiliation so
that President Solis knows who you are
what we wait I want to thank you for the
great speech that you just gave us it
seems like we should be living on a
world that should think about the
weaponize but it seems like we are in a
world that is thinking about a Tom's
race and we could only hope that more
nations act like yours that don't have
an army
so what could militarize nations can
learn from the materialized nations that
have prospered in this world such as
Costa Rica well you know the experience
of not having an army I must acknowledge
is rather unique and even when I would
advise any country to attempt to go that
way I realized that it may not be
possible I mean they sometimes even the
the notion of the of the of the
nation-state is built upon the use of
farms they need to liberate a nation
which is clearly the case of the United
States and some others so you know I
always have that when I address this
issue I always very I'm always very
careful not to give counsel too you know
and speak in general terms because it
can be a problem and I mean that can
become a historical being a historian
that's something that I take very
seriously but it is in our experience
not having an armed force as a permanent
institution has allowed the country to
use its budget elsewhere I mean talking
about dividends of peace which was a
concept that was generally associated
with the post-modernism and in the end
of the Cold War we have experienced that
for over 70 years and it has worked for
us I mean we have been able to use the
the scarce resources of the country in a
different way and that's one thing and
the second thing it has provided
stability in a region the Latin American
region when we're Armed Forces where the
Armed Forces have been generally
associated with posing serious dangers
to institutions democratic institutions
and governance yes thank you very much a
President Sirleaf an ambassador white
for coming and speaking today I'm a
student in Columbia College a senior
studying English literature and ecology
evolution and environmental biology now
someone who you know both in academia
also reading about the world at large I
was very impressed for both for your
dedication bridging academia
intergovernmental affairs into
especially critical negotiations such as
the nuclear treaty and I guess I have
one you know one main question which is
what do you think will be necessary for
the countries who do not sign on to the
nuclear treaty in the negotiations this
week and looking forward how do you
think maybe giving them an to negotiate
and
and then a not-so political question for
both of you as well and what is your
favorite Costa Rican writers thank you
the Costa Rican what I'm sorry writers
or artists artists well believe it or
not I am also placing a lot of hope in
academia to help us in this process
because it is true that there has been a
divisive dialogue the nuclear weapon
States did not believe that we the rest
of the community the national community
had to move this forward and in building
bridges I think the the academia is very
well-placed in order to provide us with
[Music]
analysis with equanimity and that is
going to create some concerts and some
bridges of how we can make the proper
interaction between the the bank treaty
and the rest of the architecture because
the ban treaty is a reality we already
have an architecture that has different
treaties and institutions and we need
innovation and creativity in order to
find new ways of interaction with this
new born a member of the family well
it's very difficult because I love music
writers or in general writers artists
people you know their creative force
inspires you so much yeah well it is
very difficult because I love music and
we have very good musicians I am I am
afraid that I would
you know leave some behind but let us
that let me just mention a couple of
them because they are like international
young ambassadors of Costa Rica one of
them is called Manuel Oregon he's a
pianist and he of course is a composer
as well and he has made this very
beautiful interaction between music and
nature and it has a beautiful
composition devoted to the rainforest
and to the dangers of destructive
rainforest symbiosis he has a very nice
composition called symbiosis which is a
piano arrangement with nature imagery
sound and it's very beautiful and the
other one is Carlos Guzman who is also a
composer and he was able to compose folk
music with classical instruments and he
is also he has created very very
beautiful pieces to make a brief comment
on academia and in politics and in
general international politics it was
very fortunate to participate as one of
the Costa Rican negotiators in the
Central American Peace plan back in 1986
and 87 I was a very young diplomat at
the time and you know it always an
impact impacted me a lot how academia
was a bridge between thinking you know
reflection and and decision-making
it was the capacity of academia to order
processes to be able to see to it put
put issues in a wider in a wider scheme
of things and I think in especially
negotiated international affair
international matters it is very
important to have more options open that
less you have to continually be looking
for Plan B
somehow and academia provides you with
that opportunity if you do not have the
scientists of also social or Natural
Sciences involved you scope tend to be
much limited and reduced and and I think
that one of the things that academics
and and people who are keen of knowledge
are able to is to put that in a war
broader sense the second thing is you
are you are better poised not to repeat
errors of the past if you know your
history well and and thirdly you can you
can compare which is another thing that
it's very important you seek for
processes that are comparable and
therefore can be relevant to the
solution was it and again as Madame
ambassador has just mentioned I'll just
mention the name of a group that is
international Costa Rican groups
international and well-known it's called
editors and they won a Grammy Award and
they you know they they were all known
for that reason and in writing I'm going
to mention the most translated Costa
Rican author Carlos Luis Sophia's FA
double a double el as5 just like phallus
he wrote a book in the 1940s called
mamita June ie which is the way the
former banana workers pronounced
United not for for a United Fruit
Company
mamita June I United and it is a it's a
it's a depiction of the life of Costa
Rica banana workers in the banana in
claim enclaves in the 1930s that has
changed a lot but the the work of
fighters was very well known and very
well taken to our door good morning
thank you so much president Solis and
ambassador for leading this treaty so
trying to find out you know to protect
the world the global peace so my
question is about I know that Latin
America almost every country in Latin
America
signed this treaty including like my
home country Venezuela so my question is
about this which mechanism the treaty
has to prevent that country like Venice
were signed this treaty and they mislead
the international community by your
lighting this treaty again so because
it's no secret that Venezuela has close
relationship with Iran and North Korea
and Venezuela I can't provide the
Iranian that they need to you know to
create this this nuclear weapons oh by
the way thank you so much for everything
that you have done to help my people in
Venezuela thank you so much
yes the ban treaty actually has a
reinforcement of norms that are placed
in other instruments like the Treaty of
the non-proliferation to which Venezuela
is tech party and the ban treaty relies
from the same system of the verification
and safeguards that was already created
by the treaty of the non-proliferation
but in even it includes the possibility
of developing new standards in in terms
of safeguards so every country that
signs enacted a Venezuela already did is
committed to having the same safeguards
agreement that that already has with the
International Atomic Energy Agency so
there is there is a complementarity and
there is no possibility of formal
shopping or bridging shopping for that
regard so the non-proliferation regime
and its verification system applies also
for this for these things I think we
should get credit to Latin America for
being at the form of the floor front of
the fight against nuclear weapons since
1968 Latin America forged a regional
agreement called the Treaty of
Tlatelolco that bans the use and
production and kept keeping and you know
all the list of ambassador mentioned of
weapons of mass destruction and nuclear
weapons in particular and we even have a
mechanism that it's a verification
mechanism for for the treaty so you know
I think that all Latin American
countries have been very much engaged in
this for a long time and it is a good
example that we would like to point out
because it makes it clear that regions
can they have the possibility of forging
these agreements and making that
possible within those territories so
obviously a country can
disrespect the or respect the the the
community but the the sanctions and the
mechanisms are in are in place
hello mr. president thank you for
speaking to us today my name is Ricardo
Tavares I study risk management at the
School of Professional Studies and I
wanted to ask you a question in terms of
cybersecurity we understand that
nowadays is a very prominent topic and
the notion that somebody with that's
highly trained and with enough resources
can just hack the access to serve to
nuclear weapons whatever how are you
helping mitigate the threats of
cybersecurity with regards to nuclear
weapons in another not so political
question if you have the opportunity to
have lunch with anybody in history who
would that person be why thank you
sure you want to address the
cybersecurity did you talk about this
yes indeed what did this John believe
that the vast majority of international
community has is the only assurance that
we have this avi cybersecurity and other
kinds of threats is the total
elimination of nuclear weapons is the
only assurance that we have I'm
regarding lunch with a historical figure
oh I have a long list I can give you a
long list of figures now I've been asked
that question several times and my
regular answer is Gandhi I would have
liked to have lunch with him but I have
a couple more one is a woman I have
always considered a very powerful figure
that I I would have liked to have known
much more to have lunch with her in her
kitchen because she is supposed to be
the person who invented the kitchen
cabinet logic which is Golda Meir the
former Prime Minister of Israel but the
other
character that's closer to us and I met
him several times but never for lunch
and I would like to see him again in
that same character is your former
President Barack Obama mr. president and
mrs. David speaking to us today
my name is Priyanka Soni I'm a first
year student at School of International
and public affairs first of all I deeply
admire your stand on the militarization
that furthers global harmony and
regional stability my question to you is
that the nuclear ban treaty is expected
to be hampered by the earlier treaty is
mentioned by you miss master like
nuclear non-proliferation treaty which
have an inherent bias against the
countries that are not p5 so how do you
propose on addressing all so mr.
president I'd like to have lunch with
mr. Gandhi too so thank you I'm sorry
can you repeat repeat your question
about the yes so the nuclear banned
treaty is expected to be hampered by the
earlier treaties such as the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty these treaties
they have an inherent bias against the
countries that are not p5 they give the
power p5 to have nuclear weapons and not
to the other countries that's the reason
countries like India Pakistan and Israel
did not sign that treaty so how do you
plan on addressing that in the nuclear
Ban Treaty well I mean it was a very
straightforward message in the
conference that as this treaty had to be
non non-discriminatory treaty and that
is the reason why you don't see
different kinds of of legal obligations
for for different kinds of countries but
on the contrary every every state that
signs needs to abide by the rules and
there is of course for the nuclear
weapon States a process in which they
will need to be accompanied by an
international community until until they
become nuclear weapon-free States but in
general terms
let's say that it's at least almost 50
years that separates one treaty from the
other all right so we are departing from
a different a different perspective and
we are departing also from the
perspective that the elimination of
nuclear weapons is a promise and the
legal obligations that the nuclear
weapon States put on the table and it's
imprinted in article six that is the
obligation to conduct negotiations in
good faith - to arrive at a nuclear
weapons free world and after the end of
the Cold War we didn't see much progress
in that regard so we depart from the
idea that the that the elimination of
nuclear weapons is an imperative for all
countries of the world and at the same
time let us remember that if the 122
countries that signed many of them are
already state parties to the treaties
the regional treaties for the
declaration of nuclear weapon-free zones
therefore we have departed from regional
treats of regional treaties to a global
norm that brings together all these all
these countries that so we train forces
the non-proliferation in the disarmament
regime hi my name is Andrew I'm a post
baccalaureate student studying pre-med
for now a few people suggest that after
the first midterms I might have to
switch to business or international
affairs but we'll deal with that when it
comes around anyway I appreciate your
work dealing with nuclear arms
proliferation etc my number one concern
is I'm taking full advantage of this
forum this week and I went to the World
Health Organization conference the other
day and their number one concern is
fighting the Zika virus this is a major
threat it's a Latin America to your
backyard my immediate thought is the
canal that's being done in Nicaragua if
you understand the history of the Panama
Canal the mosquitos being the number one
killer I would like to know how you guys
plan to address biological warfare as
well is your work with the nuclear arms
and second of all I'm not really
interested in who you guys are having
lunch with in the future I'm interested
and who you're having lunch with today
and will you have lunch with me yeah
thank you thank you very much absolutely
listen and the Zika virus yes it is a
big concern for all countries not only
in the tropical areas as you know we've
had also Zika presence in temperate
countries such as the United States in
Europe and so the only way to handle
that is through education in the
ultimate analysis because it it depends
and controlling the vectors and
and the way to do that is preventing the
mosquitoes to lay their eggs in stagnant
waters and things like that so in urban
areas that we have been dealing with
with with communities making them
understand the need to dispose of water
and in in adequately especially in
places like Costa Rica that where we we
have a long and intense rainy season
that's one thing and and I think that
the w-h-o as well as the regional health
organizations are doing a good job and
seekers by and large been dealt with
quite successfully even when the the
cases are still very abundant regarding
the canal in Nicaragua where there was
note we thought that they were gonna
build any kind of a canal and you gotta
go but it's not being built it seems to
have been anok's a hoax from from
geopolitics so there are many things
being done in Nicaragua on either canal
regarding biological warfare that's a
different area of international concern
and I think that there are other
groupings of countries that are dealing
with that but I would like to use your
question to highlight the fact that
being nuclear weapons such a significant
issue for the future of the world these
are the issues that you bring about have
more immediate and direct impacts upon
daily life
I mean nuclear weapons nuclear weapons
and the use of nuclear weapons are let's
let's hope our is unlikely I mean
generally we do not think it's going to
happen until it happens but these other
issues
Sika chemical the use of chemical
weapons climate change and the things we
don't do - and what we would happen if
we don't take measures are more
immediate I mean they are things that
are happening as we speak the use of
regular weapons Costa Rica took part in
a very strong campaign to control just
the web regular weapons the ones that
people used to kill students in
the universal or to do illegal things in
the streets and this for this we also
received high international praise under
the aureus administration or a Nobel
Peace Prize a few years back so you know
we ought to look as you mentioned to
other issues of world concern that also
kill people and they do so in large
numbers and regarding lunch I'm afraid
we'll have to go to the airport from
here so it will be next time but it will
be delightful to have lunch with I can
hold you to that thank you sir thank you
unfortunately we run out of time but I
would like to thank you Brazilians Elise
and ambassador Y for taking your time to
come and visit us in a very busy week
I'm sure and to give us a such
insightful speech on a topic they're so
relevant to the world that we live in
right now and I think I speak on behalf
of everybody here that we could only
hope that more nations could be as
forward-thinking as yours and for that
we thank you thank you very much
you